pakistan is facing a political crisis
the country's prime minister imran khan
faced a no-confidence vote in parliament
this weekend that he was set to lose
it would have effectively kicked him out
of office so khan then sought to
dissolve the legislature while the
deputy speaker a member of his own party
stopped the vote
the country is in constitutional turmoil
and it's unclear how this will play out
here's a closer look at the man fighting
for his political future
a world famous cricket star turned
populist politician
imran khan rose to power in 2018
promising anea pakistan or new pakistan
free from corruption its economy
transformed
and pakistan's powerful military a
crucial behind the scenes player
appeared to approve
my relationship uh with the army is uh
is a sensible relationship
which is uh
which is quite clear that the army
should not be running the country
so if i'm the prime minister
if i have the responsibility i have the
authority
authority that has proven slippery
the opposition jumped on his failure to
fix the economy
his anti-western rhetoric and optics may
have soured his relations with the
military who counts the u.s as a strong
ally
khan blames american-led interference
for his political troubles
[Applause]
slowly people have started to understand
what a big conspiracy has taken place
all these traitors who have been robbing
the country for the past 35 years
they've been plotting it since october
they were doing it in league with
external forces
no let me openly name america
america
his actions have thrown islamabad into
uncertainty
security is on high alert with the
matter in the supreme court
khan has vowed he won't give up power
people said to me imran khan you resign
i should resign i've played qriket for
20 years those who have played quickly
with me the cricketing world knows that
i fight until the last ball i have never
accepted defeat in my life
yet his attempt to stay in office once
again throws pakistan into political
crisis
that many hoped his promise of naya
pakistan would avoid
for more we have dw shamel shems joining
us shamal how did we get here
why do some people want kanji go
melissa the opposition parties believe
khan came to power through rigged
elections in 2018
and that the military helped him become
prime minister khan's popularity however
norse dived with
rising inflation
unemployment in the past three and a
half years
so they launched a movement to austin
through a no confidence important
parliament
though at the time they thought that the
time was right to get rid of the prime
minister that's how we reached
this point in pakistani politics
and the prime minister has blamed a
foreign conspiracy in fact an american
conspiracy for being behind
this attempt to remove him from power
can you tell us more
well khan came up with the foreign
conspiracy idea quite late after he
found out that he could not survive the
no confidence vote
he said that the u.s is backing the
opposition's no confidence vote and that
u.s assistant secretary of state donald
communicated that to a pakistani
ambassador
he has been openly accusing washington
for a conspiracy that has not been
validated
the us has categorically denied any such
thing
[Music]
now it's interesting that the country's
military chief has directly contradicted
khan's hostile position to the united
states let's have a listen to what he
had to say
equally we hear a long history of
excellent
and strategic relationships united
states which remains our largest export
market
we seek to broaden expand our ties with
both countries without impacting our
relations
with the other similarly
european union united kingdom gulf south
east asia
and japan are also vital for our
national development and progress
so shamal the military is incredibly
incredibly powerful in pakistan
will they be able to call the shots on
this
well the military especially the army
chief commander javed bajwa whom we
heard
can intervene to resolve the crisis as
this constitutional crisis is spiraling
out of control at the moment let me tell
you that it is no longer about elections
or a new pm now pakistan has huge
economic and defense ties with the us
and the army at least the army chief
believes they can't be compromised it
will imperil pakistan's economy and
security to an extent that han
supporters are not comprehending at the
moment so pakistan is at a crossroads
now the army can do a lot and the army
at the moment wants to stay neutral but
maybe it's just a matter of time that
they decide to intervene
it's a really tricky situation we have
right now one thing i'm wondering is if
khan is removed from power how likely is
it that we'll see the country's problems
especially its economic challenges
improve
well pakistan faces huge economic
challenges even if hans stays or comes
back to power on an anti-vest slogan in
next elections he will have to rely on
aid from the imf in the world bank
any other premier will have to seek
washington's help as well
han has basically raised the stakes for
pakistan's future it is no longer about
next elections let me tell you again it
is no longer about next elections it is
a make or a break up situation for the
country now with the situation in
afghanistan and the taliban in power
islamic state active in the region
this kind of chaos in pakistan is an
alarming alarming situation for the
international community and the
international community is watching it
very closely let me tell you that so it
is a very difficult scenario for
pakistan and we have to wait how things
unfold from here
shamal are you implying that the state
of democracy in the country is at stake
when you talk about the grave dangers of
the current situation
pakistan is facing a deep constitutional
crisis at the moment after the speaker
the national assembly speaker rejected
the no confidence vote he declared
almost half of lawmakers traitors
because according to his ruling they
conspired with the west with the us now
it's a very delicate situation if the
supreme court is dealing with the
situation now properly we have to see
how things unfold it's very difficult to
say how things will shape from from now
but it is going to be a very difficult
scenario for pakistani democracy and
i have this feeling that this will have
huge stakes for pakistani democracy
pakistan's constitutions and pakistani
political parties especially the
political parties
shamal shams thanks so much for joining
us as always
thanks for having me listen